hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar deciphering the crosstalk
between immunosuppressive cells and
pancreatic cancer using 3d light sheet
microscopy i am serena demers of labruz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by
miltoni biotek to learn more visit
miltoni ebiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
carol cheret lightsheet microscopy
expert at center day immunology merced
alumni
carol you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone thanks for attending this
video and thanks to miltonis for giving
me the opportunity to present my work on
the crosstalk between my read the
derived suppressor cells and regulatory
t cell in pancreatic cancer
pancreatic adjectival adenocarcinoma
also called pidak is the most common
malignancy of the pancreas
it's a highly aggressive disease with a
5 year survival rate lower than 10
projected to be the second leading cause
of cancer-related death in 2030
and
with 4 to 6 months maiden survival after
diagnosis
the main reason for this poor prognostic
is the resistance to current therapies
this therapeutic failure is due to a low
level of immunogenicity of neoplastic
cell and to a robust immunosuppressive
tumor microenvironment
this microenvironment is a real barrier
to cytotoxic agents and limits effect of
t-cell and filtration
this suggests
that this tumor microenvironment could
support cancer initiation progression
and the development of metastasis
this macron micro environment is highly
fibrotic and composed of an extensive
infiltration of immunosuppressive cells
such as tumor-associated macrophages
myeloid derived supressor cells and
regulatory g-cells
in this study we have been particularly
interested in mds and t-rex cells which
represent a nation's essential class of
immunoregulatory cells in pidak
mgac are key regulators of immune
responses in many
physiopathological conditions including
cancer
pdx sells secret factors involved in the
injection recruitment and survival of
mdc leading to ndac accumulation
and this accumulation in peripheral
circulation of passion has been related
to the extent of the disease
and associated also with a pro prognosis
concerning t-rex they are crucial for
immunomyositis and peripheral tolerance
in pidak
chile's recruitment occurs early and
are present in
pre-millennium collisions their
prevalence increases with tumor
progression and the depletion slows
tumor growth and prolongs
survival
unfold a strong influx in mdsc and t-rex
has been describing pdag there is no
evidence on the presence of a direction
between these cells
and it's also unclear if t-rex can act
on mdsc and shape the functional
differentiation
that's why we wanted to dicepher
the crosstalk between mdnc and t-rex
for that
we use an orthotropic tumor mouse model
we injected
pancreatic two cells a most pancreatic
cancer cell line and matrix directly
in the pancreas of mice we waited three
weeks to harvest the tumors and analyze
them by cytometry convocal microscopy
and light jet microscopy
first of all we wanted to characterize
the immune populations present in the
tumor
within immunochemistry
free risk suppose inoculation
and use an antarctica one to stain mjc
antibox p3 for the t-rex and anti-cd4
and cd8
for effector t-cells
we observe a strong influx of immune
cells characterized by an infiltration
of mdac
and t-rex in a tumor progress
no immune cells
were detected in a normal pancreas
we analyze also the tumor by the
cytometry and show
showed in a tumor-bearing mice a huge
increase
of cd45
plus cells in this population
we show the presence of mgac population
stained by a cd1
cd
11b and
we are characterized phenotypically of
this population
the granulocytic population
loicd plus and
6c low
and the monocytic
population
ly60 neg and ly6ci
we could observe a strong expression of
the d7h1
and the
cd40 in a both on above subset
derived from tumors however the
upregulation of f4
f4 18 and cg 124
was more substantial on the monocytic su
population
we also showed
the presence of
t-rex in this
cg-45 plus population
we observe around six percent of a cd4
process
and in this cd4 process population
alpha
are chireg so cd4 plus and fox p3 plus
in fact currently the most commonly used
marker for t-rex identification and
characterization
cd4 for speech 3
cd25 for
the interlocking 2 receptor and
the cg 1
27 for the
antarctic 7
receptor alpha we demonstrated so
that most of the
cd45 plus of cg4 plus
p3 plus
cd25 high and a cg
127 low
we show uh also very immune
immunosuppressive function of that via
the tgf beta
secretion and the expression also
expression of the markers on
ctla4
the tumeric
t-rex upregulated the tjf alpha and ctla
for expression compared to responding
control parts
we also examined the expression of ccr5
a chemokine receptor
so at the surface
of the t-rex in fact this receptor could
measure the traffic of your t-rex to
pedago tumors
mdac and oversized in the tumor
microenvironment like pancreas stellar
says can secret
at eye level
ccl5
so here we demonstrate that 20
of our tumor
t-rex express ccr5 at the surface
and we studied also the expression
of the integrin alpha e the cd
1
103
because in fact this integrin has been
reported to be an alpha mark of a tumor
infiltrating a turret in mouse colon
cancer
so
this reg
visa
cdo
103 positive t regular were described
as potential pressure of an
anti-anti-tumor immune response in this
cancer in colon cancer and
in our model we show that
more than
70 percent of the
t-rex express service molecule
we analyze after
the recruitment and the activation of
the
cd4 and cd8
t cells
so a low infiltration level was observed
in a tumor
around three percent for 38 plus cells
and four percent for
cd4 pluses we assessed the activation
set activation state of his cells
and show that
t cell down regulate the cdm 62 ligand
and
upregulate
cg
69.
more than 88 of the
entratumeral cd4 and cd8
from pdx strongly downregulate
the
cd62 ligand and
the expression of
cd69
were about 24
for 34 and 33 for cg8
since this phenotypic
markers cannot conclusively determine if
emphasizing t cells are truly naive or
functionally inactive we measure also
the intracellular level of effector
molecule interferon gamma
and our data show that 10
of the cd4 and 18 of the 38 key cell
functional produce center from ghana
should be suggesting an
activated phenotype
so pidak is characterized by a stronger
accumulation of immunosuppressive cell
population mdsc and t-rex associated
with low levels of activated
cd4 plus and cd processors
so now we wanted to characterize the
functions of every cells
to assess the supressive potential of
mgsc
we co-culture
mdic with a cd8 process and show by a
cytometry
that but cght says the
proliferation
is suppressed by um
tumoral mdac in those dependent manner
and if we indeed when we increase the
ratio mgc cells on cjt cells we increase
the ability of mdac to suppress vector
cell proliferation
we also observed when record culture
stimulated the cjt cells with mdac
from tumors that
the tumoral mjc can induce
the death of a cjt cell ex vivo
so cj t cells were cultural and jsc and
stained with a cell death marker such as
7 amg and
annexing 5
and
we observe that the percentage of alive
cells
decrease
when
the ratio and dac
from elevation density says increase
so next we examine the presence of mgac
functional molecule
such as ros for reactive oxygen spaces
and hydrogen as one which are essential
for the immunosuppressive capacity of
the cells
we observe an important app regulation
of this molecule by mjc
from pidak
compared to cjt cells
and
the
splenic counterparts
after we investigated the
supressive function of t-rex
so target cells so
34 plus
cg25 nega
where
culture with a t-rex cg4 plus and
received
plus
um
and we saw by a cytometry that
target cell proliferation
is suppressed via tumoral
t-rex
so
mgac
and t-rex from pancreatic tumor are able
to suppress
effector responses in pidak mice
so after we wanted to know if a business
cell
and they centered could interact
physically
indeed the interaction between the
these cells and different cancer models
have been proposed to play a role in
shipping the tomorrow immunosuppressive
environment
but until now
there is no evidence that this course
will could involve direct and direction
so first we determine by a confocal
microscopy the prevalence in pancreatic
tumor
the prevalence of ngac solid fear in
green
and the prevalence of a turret here in a
red
and here also the nuclei are staining
blue so we observe that the t-rex
are located in close contact to mgac
in pancreatic tumor and
never embarrassing or t-rex were
observed in
knife pancreas
so to have a 3d view of this tumor we
decided to use the lighted microscopy to
further study this interaction
so with a lighted microscope
microscopy you can image
a wall a sample and do
photoreconstruction on my reciprocal for
example
so
in this
experiment we are stain
pediatric tumor so with the same
antibodies as used in confocal
microscopic jarring from this in blue
but 3 3 4 2 eggs in green and we also
stained the blood vessel with an
anti-sma in green
the
tumor the stain
were cleared
and after image on a lighted microscope
the ultra microscope tool from
melting in biotech
and the purpose of this experiment so
was to have an idea of a cell
repartition
of mjc and direct in the tumor and see
if we can identify also interaction
between these cells
so
we can observe so here on this snapshot
uh
donna
so with embarrassed
that mdsc
in a blue and
t-rex in
red well observe
so in close contact as a
confocal microscopy
so within marisa we can also generate 3g
video and here you can see
on
this
video
like
before
so it's a little bit fast
but you can see like before the
bloodbath collection in green
were to raise in red the mdsc in blue
and also in yellow here for example
the t-rex in interaction with mjc
so we also identified interaction
between these cells with a lighted
microscopy
uh
we quantify this interaction with imares
so indeed we will be softer we can
calculate
the distance between
two different populations and
see if this cell could be an interaction
so we quantify this interaction in three
different tumors
at three weeks after inoculation and
indentified around
20 and direction
tumors but
these events are rare and
this
probably due to
their eye dynamics
we also quantify this interaction at
different points of the tumor
development one two three and four weeks
and we observe the peak of the
interaction at rest and after the number
of the integration decrease we confirm
also the presence of this interaction by
video microscopy
so our data demonstrates physical
interaction between a t-rex and mga
scene in piac
so after
we wanted to evaluate the influence of
mjc and the accumulation of t-rex in
vivo
for that
we depleted
mjc cells in pidak mice and we use we
injected entropy routinely an antibody
rb6
in the mice
and
it results in a near-complete
elimination of mgsc
in spleen but also in pancreas
and
we also observe
an inhibition of a t-rex recruitment
in a pancreatic tumor
so the systemic depletion of mgsc
can inhibit the recruitment of a t-rex
in a pancreatic tumor
to further investigate the cellular
mechanism of mdsc and t-reg interaction
we assess the ability of mjc to promote
denver development expansional
requirements of t-rex
and for that we co-culture
a t-rex
and mdsc from
[Music]
from a tumor
and when we go culture we said we show
an increase
of
the t-rex population in presence of mgcs
and if you put a transwell
chamber to separate the two population
the number of t-rex decreases
so this suggests that
t-rex injection by mdac is induced to
his job
sorry to sell cell and direction
and vice versa we tasted the t-rex
impact on mgsc
so we did a similar co-creature
and
we assessed the mjc viability so after
24 hours and
48 hours of computer
the percentage of alive sales
so a live mjc strongly increase
in the presence of a t-rex either
isolated from tumors
so our
finding
vast teres can also affect the survival
and of a proliferation of a tumoral mgsc
mjc are able
so mjc are able to industry cell
proliferation and or development in a
cell cell dependent manner
and we also show that t-rex uh cell can
affect the survival and of a
proliferation of mgmc
so to finish we wanted to determine if
uh
mba c and zero
could be an interaction in
the human pancreatic cancer so for that
we study human pitak
so we add access to paraffana invaded
tissue section for human pita
and we show
so on this section the presence of
[Music]
g cell cd4
and cd8 chisel
and we also stained uh mdac
here with an anti-11b and
an ant anti-cd11b and anti-cd15
which are the markers for human mjc and
it's not shown but no
immune cells were observed in normal
pancreas
and with a polyline
kit we
also
wanted to determine if
we can see
interruption
t-reg and
mdac cell interaction
and we observe this n direction here
uh in more than
50
percent of analyzed human pidak
so here the mdic are in peak and t-rex
are in blue
so to conclude
p-dirk is
characterized by a strong accumulation
of immunoprocess
immunosuppressive cell population mga
cmg breaks associated
with low levels of activating
effector g states
for the first time in a tumor context we
identify by lighted microscopy mjc she
arrives interaction which
which occur via direct physical contact
this interplay out of biological
relevance the individual depletion of
mjc led to a significant reduction of t
rise in payload
and
a new aspect also of our studio was
mgac t-rex enterprise contribution to
the establishment and or development of
the
immunosuppressive microenvironment in
pediak indeed we show
we showed that ndsc are able to induce
t-rays in cells independent manner and
also better tiers can affect the
survival and or reproduction of mjc
but i present molecular partners
involved in this interplay are not known
and further students are needed to
investigate this pathway
thank you for your attention and thanks
to meeting
thank you carol for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
do you have any candidates for the
molecular partners implicated in the
mdsc treg interactions
so
yes
[Music]
one
in fact one candidate to consider
could be first of a b7 ash one pedera
one
because
in mouse melanomas for example to wreck
the tan shape of a functional
differentiation on this in melanoma
and t-rex can stimulate this molecule
expressed by mdc
but
also cd40 and cd80 molecules could be
also interesting to
investigate
in fact these stimulatory molecules are
also present on mdc
in mouse colon cancer and also in
ovarian models
and they presents are also associated
with turbine's accumulation
so
these candidates could be
great thank you
the second question did you test if any
other cells besides treg could interact
with mdsc
so
yes
we only take in fact
but we did not observe any interaction
because in fact
this cell
it was shown in fact in hepatocarcinoma
that gamma delta t cell can
access the proteomeral function
by recruiting mjc but
this interaction seems to be indirect
and yes but
in
intact
in the literature there is uh
over interest interaction described like
t-rex with a
cd-11c
dc
and also overall direction like a t-rex
and thumb
for tumor associated macrophages
but we only tested the madelisa
thank you
the third question is this crosstalk
between mdsc and trag present and other
cancer types
yes
um
[Music]
[Music]
mdac expansion and
their roommate occurs uh
in a turret-dependent manner but we also
observe this crosstalk
in lung cancer
if i remember well also in colorectal
cancer and breast cancer
great
and what is your protocol to clear tumor
samples
um our protocol
the tumor
is based on
bibb
protocol
so
this method in fact is based on on
dehydration and daily predation by
organic solvent
bibb is a benz is a mix of benzyl
alcohol and benzyl benzoate
and
after
dehydration and deliberation there is a
step of error matching
and
because in fact most of the biological
samples are back and we need
a transparent sample to use like it and
so we have to remove a water lipids and
so on
fantastic
and another question we have here how
exactly do you determine mdsc trig
interactions using light sheet
microscopy
so
we determine
this interaction by imari software
in fact with imre so you can count the
cells the stained cells in the different
fluorescent channel
with
this spot function of the mares
and when you are determining this number
of to population
you can use also a matlab function in
images which allow you to measure in
fact the distance between the between
two cells
from the centroid
and
in our study
the lymphocyte we estimate that the
length of site are around 10 micrometers
in diameter and for the mdsu
20
to
230
micrometer so we asked three maurice to
determine the number of other
interaction when two cells in fact are
at the distance equals or less than 20
micrometer
awesome thank you and we have a question
coming in from
marcus
what is the basic principle of light
shaped microscopic
lighted microscopy in fact you have to
to clear your sample you can work on a
wall
sample
so and the principle of the microscope
and you have a light
a sheet of light
and you you may illuminate your sample
with this sheet and in fact
this sheet of light is a orthogonal to
the objective
and you can acquire so on level plane
illuminated by the the likeship and uh
when you have a big sample you determine
the stack but you want to cry and after
the accusation you have a stack of
picture and
you can reconstruct with this type of
picture
your entire sample
thank you and we have a question coming
in from ralph
how did you isolate the mdscs and trends
so for the isolation of the cells so we
harvest the tumor three weeks after
the inoculation and
so we dissect them in a little
fragment with scissor
and
we did the incubation with collagen as a
type one
if i remember it is 30 minutes at 37
degrees
and
after the suspension is a
[Music]
filter
and
yes we sorted the same
thank you our next question is coming in
from alejandra lopez
it's a two-part question and he's asking
what precautions should be considered to
image a tumor and light sheet
and do you suggest a protocol for
clearing and imaging in light sheets
um sorry
can you repeat the question
um
i can repeat my
the question what precautions should be
considered
to image a tumor in light sheet
and do you suggest a protocol for
clearing and imaging in light sheet
fortuna so
yeah so we use a
a protocol based on babb
but
you can use also i think i disco
protocol we didn't use i disco protocol
because
some of the
immune markers are
very responsible to methanol and in the
eye disco protocol we have a pretty
pre-treatment with methanol
so
that's why we didn't use the this uh
this protocol but i think uh for
yeah for tumors um id score will be yeah
the best because we have this
criticism with uh methanol that can
increase the
fermentation of the tumor and so
increase the penetration of antibodies
inside the tumor you have also a step of
bleaching
and
this step of vision can be used very
usable when you have
autofluorescence and in tumors sometimes
you have a lot of autofluorescence
great thank you yeah i never questions
coming from
oh go ahead i'm sorry
yeah just to mention that
when you use a disco protocol you have
to test your antibody before because
yeah as i said
you can have problem with methanol so
you have to test your antibody with on
section pretty with methanol before to
be sure that your antibody can work
with this protocol
great thank you
our next question is coming in from the
ts
is the phenotype a general occurrence in
both human and mouse tumors or is it
rather a localized
or is this rather localized
in in quotations either periphery or
core of the tumor
um
so in fact in human yeah we
you just
we identify a interaction
uh
yeah on some tumors on a parasim section
[Music]
but
in fact with them
with a human weak we had access only on
a very
small piece of tumor so
we for the localization is a difficult
process
because there is very uh very small and
we don't know exactly where we are in
the tumor
great but
yeah
our next question
are you ready for our next question
uh
yes our next question is coming in from
virginia
it's a two-part question
can you repeat which antibody you used
for mdsc's deplete
um for mgfc depletion removal
excuse me i didn't tell you well what uh
the first part of this two-part question
is from
can you repeat which antibody you use
for mds depletion
and the second part of the question
yeah so for the antibody is the airb6
hc5 antibody it's an anti-share one
yes i'm so sorry did you hear the first
the first part of the question
uh
i don't hear you
hello there is somebody
hello did you hear the first part of the
question from virginia
so uh
for the antibody right here uh so the
antibody is the
airb68c5 antibody it's an
anti jr1 antibody
fantastic thank you and the second part
of the question did you study the effect
of mdsc removal and subsequent reduction
of drag on the cancer cell population
[Music]
okay thank you so much
then the next question we have coming in
is from paul
do you have evidence for a role of cafs
in facilitating or inhibiting the
interactions that you describe for the
immune cells
no we didn't assess this question but
yes
it's known that
kaf
can have
interaction
with
mdac
and
t-rex but yeah we didn't assess
this question
thank you and our next
question is from matthias
it says
but you are measuring nucleus distance
to cytoplasm so you can never get sure
direct interaction
not in fact no in fact
imagine
do the measure from the centroid of the
cycle the nucleus to nucleus
so
[Music]
and we hypothesize that
lymphocytes are 10
10 micrometer in diameter and
the mda see a little bit more 20 and
between 20 and 13 and
we estimate
that a 20 is a good distance to be sure
that the
sell in a direction
great thank you
thank you carol do you have any final
comments for our audience
thank you carol do you have any final
comments for our audience today
hello carol thank you so much girls do
you have any final comments for today
um nurse thank you for your attention
and thank you for the question
fantastic thank you again to our
speakers carol surett for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank
labruz and our sponsor
miltoni biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during our on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available to replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye and thank you